CSS3 introduces image-set, a new value for the background
image property that let's us specify different background image
files depending solely on the display density. This won't
let us change based on layout size but we
can do that using a media query. This works
great to switch between different versions of the same
image. Image, purely based on pixel density if that's
all you need. That is, your layout size in pixels
won't change and you don't mind using background images.
If those are good for you, this is the way
to go. Foreground images are a bit trickier because you'll
either end up with an invalid HTML and no source
attribute. With problematic accessibility or you'll end up downloading
an image you don't need in the high device pixel
ratio cases. This is one place you probably don't want to
roll your own solution but use a library to polyfill
until we get the right solution. There's a great
article written by Chris Coyier That has a collection
of solution libraries that he and Christopher Schmitt have
put together. My personal favorite of these is the Picturefull
polyfill, because I think it's most likely to be
relatively close to the eventual standard solution in its markup.
But there are many other techniques with differing complexity.
For example, the clown car technique designed by Estelle Wile.
This technique makes use of SVG encapsulation, to make
each image a single reference. But to an SVG file,
that inside it has its own media query that
selectively sets a background image on the SVG object. Background
image, again, in order to prevent the browser from
downloading all of the image references early. This technique is
quite workable but its also a bit complex and markup
particularly if you want it to work in internet explorer.